i
[Música]
tokio inaugura los juegos olímpicos con
una sobria ceremonia de menos de 1000
espectadores por la pandemia del hobbit
19 las polémicas competencias aplazados
por un año se realizarán con estrictas
medidas sanitarias y en medio del
rechazo de una parte de la población
nipona que considera irresponsable la
celebración
la asamblea francesa aprobó el uso del
pase sanitario para actividades
cotidianas como la entrada a bares y
restaurantes y el uso del transporte
público la normativa también establece
la obligatoriedad de la vacunación para
el personal sanitario las autoridades
informaron que se estima una escalada de
contagios que hará que a principios de
agosto haya unos 50.000 positivos
diarios
en las próximas horas se realizará el
funeral del presidente haitiano job en
el mois asesinado el pasado 7 de julio
en la noche del jueves se llevó a cabo
una misa en honor al jefe de estado al
tiempo se realizaron protestas a favor
del mandatario en las que decenas de
personas exigieron justicia
bienvenidos a esta emisión de noticias
en france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez
y es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos
este informativo en japón donde tras un
año de aplazamiento fueron inaugurados
los juegos olímpicos de tokio como
medida para prevenir los contagios de
kobe 19 la ceremonia inicial estuvo
marcada por la sobriedad sólo 950
personas fueron invitadas al estadio
olímpico de la capital nipona que podría
albergar hasta 68 mil espectadores las
competencias se llevan a cabo en medio
de una fuerte polémica pues una parte de
la sociedad japonesa considera que
podrían convertirse en un foco de
contagios
y en el último episodio de nuestra serie
sobre los nuevos deportes olímpicos
cerramos con escalada deportiva una
categoría que se ha popularizado y que
durante esta edición tendrá un formato
especial veamos el informe sobre los
secretos y cualidades de este deporte
dificultad
y velocidad estas son las tres pruebas
de la escalada deportiva en el circuito
profesional
cada una tiene sus campeones pero en el
programa olímpico las tres disciplinas
se combinan
una federación internacional decidió
para evitar que una de las modalidades
quedara fuera hacer una mezcla de las
tres combinando las disciplinas
por eso es que hay estas tres pruebas
los atletas que participarán no son
especialistas de las 33 disciplinas muy
diferentes en dificultad escalar una vía
de 15 metros quien llegue más cerca de
la cima gana el molde es más técnico
escalar el máximo de vías fijas en una
pared de 4.5 metros de altura la
velocidad es sencilla el primero en
llegar
en cada disciplina hay que llevar un
factor al máximo ser explosivo en
velocidad
el factor fuerza la imaginación y la
creatividad en boulder en dificultad el
esfuerzo es más largo entonces se
necesita capacidad de adaptación toma de
información y regulación
los atletas están obligados a repasar lo
aprendido y funciona se trata de
autocontrol es como regresar a la
escuela para aprender una nueva
disciplina un nuevo deporte y con
paciencia y aplicación se logra
progresar a la aplicación alguna vez
ofrece a mediados del siglo 20 los
alpinistas se reunieron en clubes para
entrenarse e intentar hacer sus cada vez
más peligrosos los muros artificiales
surgieron con las competiciones modernas
lo que permite preservar las paredes
naturales unos 40 años más tarde la
escalada llega a los juegos olímpicos
safa lo combina beckett fallece fin del
combinado las tres disciplinas es un
primer paso luego en parís en 2024 se
dará otro paso ya que se separa la
velocidad del búlder y la dificultad
la escalada es un deporte joven que
tiene cada vez más adeptos en el mundo
es su objetivo que quede inscrita en la
aventura olímpica de manera permanente
la asamblea nacional francesa ratificó
el polémico proyecto de ley que
establece la obligatoriedad de la
vacunación para todos los trabajadores
de la salud la normativa también hace
que en lugares cotidianos los ciudadanos
deban mostrar su pase sanitario que
prueba inmunidad al virus la medida del
gobierno de manuel ma con busca a
acelerar la vacunación sin embargo
enfrentan numerosas críticas en la clase
política y en la sociedad suscripta la
votación ha terminado después de toda
una noche con horas de intenso debate el
último proyecto de ley del gobierno de
manuel macrón contra el kobe se aprobó
en la asamblea nacional con 117
diputados a favor y 86 en contra es una
victoria para macro ni su partido que
llegó tras una dura lucha en el
legislativo y con una serie de protestas
en las calles la mayoría de los miembros
del parlamento aparte de los de extrema
derecha izquierda radical estuvieron a
favor de la medida que requiere que
todos los trabajadores de salud se
vacunen sin embargo la propuesta de
macrón del pase sanitario que requiere
una prueba de vacunación o un test
negativo para entrar en una serie de
lugares incluidos restaurantes
o los ánimos entre los diputados
he escuchado a miembros de la mayoría de
decir que siempre merece la pena
intentarlo
como si esto fuese una cosa trivial
aplastamos libertades personales pedimos
documentos a la gente en cualquier sitio
y voy a evitar el micrófono como hizo
usted señor rufián para asegurarme que
me escuchan si necesitamos este pase de
manera inmediata ahora no estamos aquí
para molestar a la gente estamos aquí
para protegerlos para legislar y para
salir adelante con el número de casos en
aumento el gobierno prometió acelerar el
proyecto de ley tras su éxito en la
asamblea esa rapidez también fue un
objeto de críticas se han realizado unas
1200 enmiendas en un debate que comenzó
en la tarde del miércoles y acabó
finalmente el viernes a las 5 de la
mañana esta es la novena ley anti kobe
del gobierno que ahora se enfrentará a
un agitado proceso en el senado
tal como lo ha hecho francia italia
buscará implementar el uso del pase
sanitario para bares restaurantes y
otros lugares de ocio a partir del 5 de
agosto el ejecutivo aprobó un decreto
que establece la obligatoriedad del
llamado certificado verde que demuestra
que la persona ha sido vacunada superó
la enfermedad o tiene una prueba
negativa para entrar a lugares como
cines museos y estadios para que la
norma entre en vigor tendrá que recibir
el aval del parlamento italiano
y una mesura con koubbi el certificado
verde es una medida que permitirá a los
italianos seguir practicando sus
actividades disfrutando yendo al
restaurante a participar a espectáculo y
alberto participar en espectáculos al
aire libre y en interiores con la
garantía de estar entre personas que no
contagian tiene un solo culto a dios en
el gobierno del presidente joe biden
sancionó al ministro de las fuerzas
armadas de cuba y a una unidad militar
de élite conocida como boinas negras por
reprimir las protestas
antigubernamentales del pasado 11 de
julio en la isla las sanciones del
departamento del tesoro de eeuu bloquean
todos los activos del ministro álvaro
lópez miera uno de los hombres de
confianza del ex presidente raúl castro
y de todos los integrantes de la brigada
especial nacional del ministerio del
interior por su parte el canciller
cubano bruno rodríguez señaló que las
sanciones son irrelevantes
y en las próximas horas está previsto
que se realice el funeral del presidente
de haití yo en el mois asesinado el
pasado 7 de julio en cap-haitien cerca
de la ciudad natal del mandatario se
celebró una misa en su honor esta
localidad ubicada al norte del país es
la única que ha protestado por su
asesinato
herminia fernández nos cuenta los
detalles
yo en el mois fue un presidente con baja
popularidad pero aún así tienes
seguidores que lloran su muerte al norte
de haití en cabo haitiano ciudad vecina
al pueblo natal de moix se celebró una
misa en su honor y los asistentes se
mostraron enfadados por su muerte
justicia para el presidente justicia
para mi presidente no voté por una
muerte como ésta murió como un criminal
como un asesino no voté para que muriera
así pues cabo haitiano ha sido uno de
los epicentros de las protestas por la
muerte de maurice sus habitantes se
quejan de la pasividad policial en el
magnicidio una ira que ha llegado hasta
la capital las barricadas se extendieron
en puerto príncipe
la gente quiere gritar todos están
protestando porque el presidente joven
él está muerto por eso todos están
tristes por eso la gente bloquea las
calles
mientras tanto las autoridades de haití
preparan para este viernes el funeral
nacional del ex presidente que fue
asesinado el 7 de julio hasta este
momento hay 26 personas detenidas entre
ellos ex militares colombianos quienes
ingresaron a la casa oficial del
mandatario sin encontrar resistencia por
parte de la seguridad presidencial
ya son al menos 47 las víctimas de las
fuertes lluvias y deslizamientos que
golpean el estado de maharashtra en el
occidente de india las acumulaciones de
agua han obligado a las autoridades a
utilizar helicópteros ya llamar a los
ciudadanos atrapados a esperar el
rescate sobre los tejados a su vez en
china los fallecidos por las
inundaciones aumentaron a 51 las fuertes
lluvias que golpean el centro del país
se desplazan hacia el norte casi 400.000
personas han tenido que ser evacuadas
por el fenómeno cuyos daños han sido
evaluados en alrededor de 10 millones de
dólares
llegamos hacia el final de esta emisión
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía y
feliz día para todos
[Música]